après la découverte du corps des deux
victimes ont château de donchery selon
les indications les aveux du tueur en
série michel fourniret l'enquète ne fait
que commencer
d'autres points seront entreprises
michel fourniret avoué neuf meurtres sa
femme on évoque 10 il pourrait y en
avoir davantage
invité de ce journal charpenay le
procureur général de reims key systems
recherches hier en alsace les corps de
julie jeune marie edwige découvert cette
semaine pourraient montrer des
similitudes troublantes
l'anc est de le dire le tour de france
avec la première étape de 102 km entre
liège et charleroi le suisse conserve le
maillot jaune sur la route du tour le
rendez-vous des fous de la finale de
l'euro 2004 dans un peu plus d'une heure
coup d'envoi en direct sur france 2 au
stade de la luz à lisbonne une affiche
inédite portugal grèce des supporteurs
des deux camps se préparent au choc de
la rencontre
avignon prend un tournant et secoue la
tradition très vite festival l'année
dernière avec une nouvelle équipe à sa
tête le grand rendez vous théâtral
commence plus tôt et dans la rue au delà
des remparts madame monsieur bonsoir
dans l'actualité de ce dimanche la fin
des fouilles au château de soutou dans
les ardennes marque une première étape
de l'enquète sur michel fourniret les
aveux du tueur en série sont donc
authentifié avec ses preuves matérielles
on peut espérer que d'autres affaires de
meurtre seront élucidées les deux corps
retrouvés hier sont bien ceux de la
fillette belge elisabeth brichet de
l'étudiante française jeanne marie des
marots mais le travail de la justice ne
fait que commencer le point amaury
guibert infanti au château de sceaux
tout ce matin il ne reste que deux
engins de chantier ici une parcelle de
terre retournée les traces des foot
d'hier le dispositif de sécurité lui a
été levée hier soir michel fourniret a
été remis aux policiers belges sur cet
ancien poste frontière
toujours accompagné de sa femme monique
olivier
retour en belgique donc après une
journée de fouille macabre encadrés par
des enquêteurs belges et français michel
fourniret est revenu dans son ancien
domaine avec précision il est indiqué
deux endroits là où reposent les corps
de deux de ses victimes en fin de
journée les recherches aboutissent les
fouilles s'arrête ici parce que nous
avons abouti dans cette commission
rogatoire je crois qu'au niveau français
également tous les renseignements que
l'on avait dans ce dossier ont été
exploités ici à ce tout j'espère qu'on y
reviendra pas voilà la fin de 15 ans
dans quête quinze ans après la
disparition de jeunes marie des rameaux
à charleville mézières et celle
d'elizabeth brichet à namur en belgique
un rapt auxquelles auraient participé
monique olivier ici au centre de l'image
selon les enquêteurs en l'état actuel du
dossier aucun autre corps ne repose au
château de sceaux tout mais d'autres
victimes présumées de michel fourniret
n'ont toujours pas été retrouvés
les familles des victimes qui
attendaient depuis des années la
terrible certitude il y à la fin d'une
épreuve et le début du travail de deuil
mais aussi la tente que justice soit
rendue michel le fournirait pourrait
être jugé en france
yasmina farber frédéric vion à 83 ans
henri des rameaux est anéantie par la
nouvelle après 15 ans d'espoir il a la
certitude aujourd'hui que sa fille
disparue est décédé
c'est fini pour moi marmonne le vieil
homme jeune mari était étudiante elle
avait 22 ans quand elle disparaît en
mars 89 devant la gare de charleville
mézières
depuis son père vivait dans la tente
comme le confirme un voisin il y avait
l'espoir de la retrouver quand même
qu'en ville c'est ça le seul espoir que
quelqu'un qui va retrouver son proche
1,6 envie qu'il est croyant qu'on a oui
très fort la disparition d'elizabeth
briché 12 ans et plus depuis 89 très
médiatisée en belgique
la télévision consacré régulièrement des
émissions pour tenter d'élucider ce
mystère
au fil des années sa famille avait aussi
gardé l'espoir je laime toujours que son
frère l'aiment toujours et que et que on
l'attend fois qu'ils soient arrivés
c'est certainement une délivrance pour
les parents pour le frères d'elisabeth
et j'irai pour leur conseille aussi
parce que bon ça fait quand même une
quinzaine d'années que nous sommes dans
cette ambiance d'anxiété d'incertitude
le couple royal a tenu à inviter le père
d'elizabeth brichet de part et d'autre
de la frontière
deux familles vont enfin pouvoir donner
une sépulture à leurs enfants
elle met aussi un visage sur l'homme qui
a brisé leur vie
je vous propose maintenant d'écouter le
témoignage que celle qui a été violée à
l'âge de 14 ans par michel fourniret
c'était le 4 septembre 1982 dany n'a le
guen en est l'une des rares victimes à
l'époque avoir porté plainte de noix
bringer
c'était il ya vingt deux ans en 1982 des
inhalants gainant à 14 ans lorsqu'elle
croise la route de michel fourniret
je rentrais chez moi il m'a accosté la
vie une bouteille qui m'a t-il dit
contenait du vitriol il m'a dit écoute
et voilà je vais vous prendre en otage
puisque
je voulais une voiture j'ai poursuivi
par la police donc c'est un scénario ça
c'est pas quelqu'un qui agit sous une
occupation n'est d'accord et je ne vous
ferais rien si vous me suivez
si vous dépassez pas s'ils ne criez pas
michel fourniret abusera finalement de
daïna le gainey il sera condamné à sept
ans prison mais n'ira pas au bout de sa
peine
traumatisée elle se souvient de son
agresseur
quel type d'homme c'était entre est
calme posé mois il a pleuré après ils
m'ont raconté sa vie m'a raconté qu'il
était à la recherche de la virginité
ce qui revient d'ailleurs je crois dans
ses propos encore maintenant mais très
posé et il n'a pas semblé dément il n'a
pas semblé fou il me semble pas du tout
en cultive son garçon moi il me semble
plutôt très calculateur j'ai beaucoup de
peine pour les familles des 11 victimes
j'ai un curieux sentiment de culpabilité
dans le sens où je me dis que peut-être
que six mois il avait été plus loin avec
moi et donc peut-être que s'il m'avait
tuez moi et qu'ils se soient phare est
après marine aurait il sa reste en
prison jusqu'à la fin de sa vie et il en
aurait pas tuer 10 au pour tout cas 10
connu neuf ou dix connu tu ne sens pas
bien mais en même temps j'ai vraiment la
rage quoi et la rage
je me dis si ce témoignage suis mon
témoignage qui le faites moi d'avoir été
savez une de ses victimes de m'en être
sorti en tout cas physiquement
si ça peut faire en sorte que d'autres
filles viennent témoigner que d'autres
personnes se manifestent et que lui
reste vraiment définitivement prison si
on peut arrêter de lui trouver des
excuses
ben voila je serai contente si on
connaît quelques dates clés dans le
parcours criminel de michel fourniret il
a été condamné en 87 à sept ans de
prison dont deux avec sursis pour viol
sur mineure ce multirécidiviste présente
une personnalité troublante complexe un
homme froid qui n'a jamais été forestier
contrairement à ce qui a été dit un
homme intelligent cultivé à l'apparence
donc presque tranquille et rassurante
yann fronty d'alicja pour certains il
n'était qu'un simple forestier un métier
qu'il n'a en fait jamais exercé
michel fourniret savait jouer et rusé
avec son apparence
aujourd'hui il se révèle être un
personnage beaucoup plus complexe que la
simple image de bûcheron un peu rustre
que l'on pouvait avoir de lui
gérard et jocelyne cadets sont peut-être
les seuls à avoir bien connu pendant
plus de trois ans ils ont été très
proches au point d'être choisi comme
témoin de son mariage
aujourd'hui ils ont le sentiment d'avoir
été manipulé il ya aucun aucun détail
qui nous a fait soupçonner quoi que ce
soit rien du tout au contraire
au contraire c'était même un gars qui
dégageait une certaine intelligence qui
dégage n1 certain caractère c'était un
gars qui était propre toujours bien
habillé courageux bosseur jamais on
aurait pu penser à un truc pareil jamais
jamais jamais jamais
car au premier abord michel fourniret
ressembler à monsieur tout le monde
un homme réservé mais plutôt sympathique
au physique qui ne laissait rien
transparaître dans le village de sart
custinne où il a habité jusqu'à son
arrestation il ya un an
on se souvient d'un voisin intelligents
au langage soigné et surtout très
besogneux
il parlait un très beau français un très
beau français en france très très très
châtié
nous l'avons vu travailler très
travailleur et kb de l'or dans ses mains
comme on dit d'habitude mais on ne
savait pas que jamais avait servi à
autre chose
passionné d'échecs michel fourniret a
passé sa vie à jouer avec ceux qu'il a
côtoyés un jeu pervers dont on ne
connaît pas encore le nombre exact de
victimes avec nous à yves charpenel
bansard d'être procureur général de
raser donc participé hier à cette
journée de fouilles aux côtés de michel
fourniret
qu'est ce que vous avez retenu du
personnage qu'est ce qui vous a aimé ou
troubler ce qui est troublant c'est le
contraste entre ce personnage
effectivement qui n'est pas surprenant
quand on le voit qui est très posé qui
effectivement s'exprime très calmement
en très bon français et l'atrocité
absolue des choses qu'ils racontaient
qu'il a fait
vous avez pu dire un joueur d'échecs
c'est un joueur d'échecs et c'est un
chasseur c'est aussi un manipulateur
vous mélangez les trois et vous avez ce
personnage tout à fait tout nous on a le
sentiment qu'il a plusieurs modes
opératoires c'est exact oui en réalité
on croit comprendre on commence à
connaître maintenant son parcours
criminel
il ya d'une part cette chasse aux jeunes
filles ils appellent ça la chasse aux
vierges et puis après ils tuent pour pas
être ennuyé et puis d'autre part ils
tuent aussi mais simplement pour avoir
de l'argent
alors on a vu en 87 il a été condamné
pour viol sur mineure est ce qu'on
pouvait imaginer qu'il allait passer du
viol crime et bien évidemment on
rétrospectivement ceci dit les experts
les experts psychiatres de l'époque
avait bien senti que la personnalité
déjà très inquiétante de michel
fourniret pouvait cacher des choses
encore pires ça veut dire que la justice
n'a pas écouté n'a pas entendu je crois
qu'à cette époque effectivement la
justice était beaucoup moins habitués à
cette problématique et n'a pas n'avaient
pas les moyens d'ailleurs leygonie
peut-être la curiosité pour se dire
qu'après une peine
peut-être il fallait faire attention à
laurenan l'impression que l'on fait ne
fait que commencer dans quelle direction
est ce que des fouilles vont reprendre
est ce qu ont contraint ce sont les
interrogatoires
comment avez vous procédé eh bien on va
commencer d'abord par essayer d'avoir
des informations plus précises sur les
cas que nous connaissons encore mal il
n'est pas question pour nous d'aller
fouiller au hasard et donc nous allons
essayer de de continuer à obtenir et des
époux fourniret et des témoignages et
des éléments matériels des moyens de
progresser dans la recherche de la
vérité
alors concrètement est ce qu'il sera
jugé en france est ce qu'il y aura
plusieurs magistrats en charge
comment vont faire les choses de part et
d'autre de la frontière france belgique
on va essayer d'abolir les frontières je
crois que les deux ministres de la
justice français belges travaillent
ensemble là dessus on va essayer de
faire en sorte que tout ça soit cohérent
c'est à dire qu'il y ait si possible une
seule équipe de juges qui travaille pour
obtenir un seul procès pour l'ensemble
des crimes qu'il a commis
est-ce que derrière les barreaux vous
avez le sentiment que michel fourniret
manifeste encore d'une certaine façon sa
puissance naturellement je crois que
c'est sa structure de personnalités on
le voit bien puisque il sait maintenant
à l'âge qu'il a avec les crimes qu'il a
commis
qu'ils ne devraient pu ressortir de
prison et donc il essaie encore de
manifester qu'il a la maîtrise de leur
évasion par exemple en indiquant à qui
il veut parler à qui il ne veut pas
parler on peut imaginer que le
les crimes 9 ou 10 selon son épouse
pourrait dépasser ce que ça faisait que
dans son parcours que vous avez rappelé
il ya une longue période de dix années
où il a disparu du champ judiciaire et
on a du mal à imaginer que par lancer
des années ne s'est rien passé et nous
attendons beaucoup des victimes ou des
témoins qui vont se manifester parce
qu'ils n'auront pas peur de le faire
sachant que maintenant
michel fourniret vraiment entre les
mains de la justice un mot un dernier
mot concernant son épouse on a un
sentiment d'un rôle actif alors
s'agit-il d'une complicité active d'une
femme qui subit qui a peur qu'ils
participent c'est tour c'est troublant
c'est un cas qu'on ne voit pas souvent
c'est tout à la fois c'est manifestement
quelqu'un qui a peur c'est manifestement
quelqu'un de soumis et c'est aussi
quelqu'un d'actif qui participe
pleinement aux crimes les plus atroces
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
autre affaire qui suscite la hausse il
est froid en alsace après la découverte
du corps de la petite julie hier on
reste sous l'émotion et le choc dans son
village natal ce matin l'adolescente
était dans toutes les pensées anouk
burel lionel feirstein l'avis de
recherche est encore sur toutes les
boutiques du village dans tous les
esprits
le maire lui n'affiche plus que sa peine
lui jours qu'ils accroché un espoir
le corps de julie a été retrouvé hier à
une trentaine de kilomètres de là
le maire a passé la soirée avec les
parents et mon oncle pendant très
gentiment dans des circonstances que
vous connaissez
je trouve qu'ils font preuve d'une
grande dignité dans ces moments
terribles
je crois aussi que j'étais soulagé
compte tenu des circonstances d'avoir
retrouvé l'enfant la tristesse gagner le
village tous voisins amis bénévoles ont
participé aux recherches dès le premier
jour la tristesse la colère aussi
depuis que c'est écrit noir sur blanc
révolté révolté révolté tout le monde y
pense un petit peu petit
j'irai même une psychose dans le secteur
concernant cette affaire
on n'a pas attendu pour prier dès qu'on
a su que je lis avait disparu et ça nous
a tellement ému les parents de julie
appel à une marche silencieuse samedi
prochain pour nous c'est trop tard
dit-il
mais nous ne voulons pas que cela puisse
se reproduire en une semaine en alsace
trois corps ou d'enquêté retrouver celui
de julie de jeunes mariés d'edwige des
similitudes troublantes qui pourrait
faire le lien avec pierre bonin écroué
depuis jeudi
ce multirécidiviste surnommé pierrot le
fou n'est poursuivi que dans une seule
affaire celle de julie christelle
bertrand jean pierre pasteur
l'endroit n'a pas encore retrouvé son
calme habituel ce matin encore la police
scientifique procèdent à des relevés ou
julie a été découverte depuis plusieurs
jours l'enfant gisait à moitié dévêtue
au bord de ce ruisseau pierre bodin est
le suspect numéro 1 mais il nie tout
pourtant des traces de son sang était
sur le vélo de julie et des taches du
sang de julie ont été trouvées dans la
voiture de celui que l'on surnomme
pierrot le fou depuis plusieurs semaines
la région est secouée par trois affaires
aux coïncidences troublantes
le corps de jeanne marie 11 ans lui
aussi a été abandonnée sans vie dénudée
au bord de ce cours d'eau
les similitudes entre les deux affaires
laisse perplexe je m'interroge sur
l'application éventuelle éventuel dis-je
de bodin dans le crime de john barry
ces fleurs sont pourris devis cheval et
à quelques kilomètres des deux premières
victimes le corps de la jeune femme de
38 ans est aperçu par un pêcheur dans un
ruisseau dénudées exactement comme julie
et jeanne-marie dès le début de l'
enquête sur la mort des deux biches
vallée des autorités communiquent des
dix talent elles portent en effet
des traces de strangulation et plusieurs
blessures par arme blanche
les trois victimes auraient pu subir le
même genre de violence dans la caravane
de pierre bodein les enquêteurs sont
toujours à la recherche d'un 10 ils
veulent savoir si sa présence dans le
périmètre des trois affaires est une
pure coïncidence
en corse le mitraillage de la façade de
la gendarmerie de pietrosella été
revendiqué par le flnc union des
combattants deux hommes circulant à moto
ont ouvert le feu hier cette gendarmerie
avait déjà été partiellement détruite
par un attentat à l'explosif quelques
mois avant l'affairé rignac et c'est là
que le commando aurait dérobé larmes qui
a servi à tuer le préfet michèle alliot
marie condamne cette agression à
l'étranger la décapitation d'un marine
enlevés en irak est annoncé comme
callière est loin d'être confirmé une
certaine confusion en fait entoure cette
affaire l'armée américaine a affirmé ce
matin qu'il n'y avait aucune preuve que
cet homme d'origine libanaise et été
mises à mort et cet après midi le site
internet de l'organisation islamiste
incriminé qui dément l'exécution aux
états unis ce 4 juillet le jour de la
fête nationale célébrant l'indépendance
de l'amérique une date symbole l'état
d'alerté élevée dans tout le pays
et c'est aujourd'hui qu'a été posée la
première pierre de la tour de la liberté
à new york jerome béni jour symbolique
celui de la fête nationale américaine
pour poser sur le site de l'ancien world
trade center
la première pierre de la future tour de
la liberté sa hauteur sera elle aussi
symbolique 542 m soit 1776 pieds l'année
de l'indépendance américaine
mais le spectre du 11 septembre 2001
n'est pas pour autant dissipées
la menace terroriste est toujours là les
cérémonie placée sous haute surveillance
19 postes de contrôle filtre la foule au
centre de washington où sera donné un
concert gratuit
c'est à l'écart de la capitale en
virginie occidentale que le président
bush fait son allocution rendant hommage
au sacrifice des soldats américains dans
la guerre en irak qui continue de
présenter comme une guerre pour
l'indépendance et demain l'algérie fait
les 42 ans de son indépendance
l'occasion nous intéresser aux jeunes
qui sont les forces vives du pays
nous sommes allés au rang afin de savoir
à quoi révèle la jeunesse florence
bukiya didier deshamps smoke dini booba
les pseudonymes de ces rappeurs zoran
les jeunes qui ressemble à s'y méprendre
à ceux des banlieues françaises
mêmes causes mêmes tenues même rythme
même révolte contre un quotidien
difficile pour moi concours étudiant
chômage donc avec le groupe 5 derrière
ma mère mon père ma soeur ma ferme at
her mon frère ma soeur qui ont et moi un
héros d' sur chômage et ça travaille pas
que personne n'ait vu comment faire qui
travaille très dur pour lui mais je veux
l'idée mais j'arrive pas sur le chômage
mais se fait du business quoi ça c'est
des motos je les revends ses montres
portable du bifff légal légal pour moi
une seule vie aux populations vivent
grâce au système d seul moyen pour ces
jeunes de s'en sortir
60% des algériens ont moins de 20 ans
auront seconde ville du pays comptent
tout autant de chômeurs que le reste du
territoire
29% officiellement les jeunes zohra née
tiennent un discours contradictoire
ils affirment aimer leur vie
mais espère pouvoir quitter leur pays
zinédine zidane reste leur star
incontestée et la france est toujours
leur eldorado pour les ingérer tu ne vis
pas bien c'est gentil l'alliance
il y en a qui vivent très bien
beaucoup de chanteurs vivre bien pour
amin signifie d'abord avoir les moyens
financiers de profiter de la douceur des
nuits zoran sur la corniche les cabarets
à la mode drainent une clientèle de tout
âge venait du pays tout entier voire de
marseille de paris on applaudit chabab
12 nouvelles stars du raï en algérie
oran soigner sa réputation celle d'une
ville à part faite de tolérance et de
recherche du plaisir c'est cabaret n'ont
jamais fermé
même durant les années de terreur
islamiste en gironde
ouverture aujourd'hui d'un nouveau port
de plaisance ouvert à la fois sur
l'atlantique et vers le sud il s'agit du
seul port construit dans le pays depuis
ces dix dernières années au moment où
l'engouement pour la navigation de
plaisance est telle qu'il ya un vrai
manque de place david base et bernard
bonne âme c'est un joyau le phare de
cordouan qui indique le chemin vers le
tout nouveau port médoc puis l'estuaire
de la gironde que l'on remonte pour
atteindre tout juste sorti des eaux en
face de royan l'escale de port médoc
bonjour je vous demande l'autorisation
de rentrer dans vos américain
encore des saillies les premiers
voiliers peuvent accoster 800 anneaux de
stationnement sont à vendre
une aubaine dans le monde de la
plaisance française ou cinquante mille
propriétaires attendent désespérément un
emplacement pour leur embarcation
car maupin section d'arcachon 25 ans
d'avoir une place des amoureux du
nautisme qui déboursent entre 15 et 45
mille euros pour être propriétaire d'un
bout de pontons cela mérite un baptême
au champagne car un plaisancier
dépensent en moyenne 3800 euros par an
pour cette région enclavée du nord-médoc
cela veut dire des emplois et de
l'activité aérienne sa poule et et il ya
le tourisme c'est tout alors c'est
presque deux mois ça dure deux mois -
demi deux mois
il ya une activité qui a mené par la
plaisance une activité hôtelière de
tourisme le commerce d'entretien des
bateaux qui dans tous les ports c'est
évident de l'activité mais sans
bétonnage des mesures et les
constructeurs ont bâti ici le premier
port écologique de france les eaux usées
garrigue dans ce circuit passe dans une
de ces deux pentes à partir de là elles
sont évacuées sous vide et impressionne
vers la station d'épuration de la ville
du verdon-sur-mer 50% des anneaux ont
trouvé preneur à port médoc
on espère que la généreuse bénédiction
du curé de la paroisse décidera d'autres
acheteurs et pour tous les adeptes du
vtt dans le plus grand domaine skiable
du monde la cinquième édition dans les 3
vallées pour les amoureux de la montagne
méribel didier guyot fini privé avec le
en route pour 500 km de pistes à travers
les 3 vallées aujourd'hui l'esprit de
compétition reste aux vestiaires place à
la balade en vtt au milieu des montagnes
une journée entre amis ou en famille le
vtt entre les mains pour visiter des
sous-bois ou dévaler des sentiers les
spécialistes sont devant les débutants
eux prennent du temps on peut se mettre
chacun à son niveau mais je pense pas
très très bon et puis bon je passe j'ai
jamais eu l'impression des paquets
finalement ça se passe bien et c'est
super il a pour tous les goûts toutes
les douleurs ravitaillement de méribel
vous aurez barbecue régionales et
justement après l'effort et les douleurs
le réconfort un millier de participants
qui pédalent des heures sur le soleil il
faut penser à l'eau et à la nourriture
il ya de la souffrance mais c'est avant
tout une journée plaisir pour les yeux
c'est vraiment du plaisir
ouais et même le terrain et c'est très
varié tout super pour l'instant ça va
bien sur la meme chose et on oublie la
souffrance du goût pour l'instant n'y a
pas trop de souffrance encore france a
sera lé prochain km à venir voilà
comment bonne route aussi et puis avant
de quitter les lieux ne pas oublier la
photo souvenir le mont blanc en
arrière-plan et des images planète sport
ce dimanche avec la première étape du
tour de france 202 km entre liège et
charleroi les 188 coureurs ont été
encouragés par un public venu nombreux
sur la route du tour nathanaël de
rincquesen et sylvain doba un petit coin
de parapluie pour une place au paradis
les belges aiment le tour et ça se voit
aujourd'hui sur les routes de la
wallonie ils n'ont pas hésité à se
mouiller pour voir passer le peloton
c'est exceptionnel quand même le tour de
france dont convient loin se déplace
bien sûr tomberait même décor planté
place à l'heure des coureurs il ne pleut
pas des cornes mais si tout comme la
chaussée est trempé le peloton est
tendue les premières chutes ne se font
pas attendre bradley mcgee quatrième au
classement général voit s'envoler ses
rêves de maillot jaune plus de peur que
de mal mais à l'arrivée il perd 6
minutes ce soir l'australien et 186e le
tour ne se gagne pas en un jour mais il
peut se perdre en quelques secondes les
ingrédients pour pour commencer un tour
du bon ok c'est vrai qu'il a fallu deux
vigilant et a eu beaucoup de glissades
et des routes
pas facile la pluie bombe à un petit peu
le le stress du premier jour sur la
ligne
la pluie laisse bientôt la place aux
sprinteurs on attendait petacchi et on
retrouve kirsi pu un estonien de 36 ans
qui fait le bonheur de son équipe
française notre tour est déjà et déjà
gagné mais on va essayer de pas
s'arrêter là bien sûr puisque mais je
pense que ça peut que décontracté
l'équipe sens sachant que mal an c'est
que du bonheur fabian cancellara lui
voit toujours la vie en jaune pour son
plus grand bonheur
l'enthousiasmé des supporteurs qui
viennent voir passer des champions doit
être canalisée pour éviter tout accident
il y en a eu par le passé aujourd'hui
des mesures de sécurité une campagne ont
été mises en place pour protéger le
public et les coureurs julien beaumont
leurs anciens à chaque passage c'est la
même chose
cohue générale dans public la caravane
et ses cadeaux attire
attention danger c'est justement ce que
rappelle cette voiture tous les jours
des conseils de prudence simple mais
obligatoire il faut apporter toutes ces
consignes pour parce que les gens on
s'aperçoit il ya toujours
malheureusement des parents ou des
enfants qui sont distraits et donc pour
cela il faut leur apporter toujours ce
message et les mettre en garde
message bien reçu dans le public
la 4 ans à être excité par
l'effervescence de la fête mais je le
tiens pour éviter les accidents
rien de tel que des chauffeurs bien
formés jean-marie par exemple a
longtemps transporter des hommes
politiques
un cv qui a facilité sa sélection qui
nous font passer des tests de conduite
déjà provence on est à deux bonds à
pouvoir conduire ce genre de véhicule
prévention mais aussi répression chaque
jour des contrôles de vitesse sont
effectués ou alors l'année dernière nous
avons
une estimation à peu près 1000 contrôles
et sucé remis le contrôle je crois
savoir qu une cinquantaine ont été
réprimandés 21 mille personnes
s'occupent de la sécurité
un important dispositif pour ne pas
revivre la catastrophe 2002 date du
dernier accident mortel sur le tour de
france
en tennis à wimbledon le suisse roger
federer conserve de son titre il a battu
cet après midi l'américain andy roddick
en quatre sets 4 6 2 7 5 7 6 6 4
une finale interrompue plusieurs fois
par la pluie la finale de l'euro 2004
aura lieu tout de suite après ce journal
en direct sur notre chaîne le portugal
est en effervescence et à lisbonne des
dizaines de milliers de supporteurs ont
formé une immense chaîne humaine tout au
long du trajet qui a suivi leur équipe
pour atteindre le stade chez les
supporteurs grecs qui sont venus par
avion entier ces derniers jours on est
sûrs de la victoire mais pas sûr du tout
d'avoir des billets pour voir le match
manuel tisser nadine picard tout va se
jouer là le dénouement de presque un
mois de compétition au stade de la luz
le stade de la lumière
à quelques minutes du coup d'envoi de la
finale de l'euro l'ambiance monte aux
abords de l'enceinte plutôt fraternelles
entre deux nations qui se retrouve pour
la première fois à ce niveau
le bleu et le blanc de la grèce le rouge
et le vert du portugal se mélangent dans
la bonne humeur et parfois la tendresse
à ce quoi la faute
n'importe qui car ils contents pour moi
moi je ferai le corps d'un homme très
trop mal
à cette heure-ci difficile de trouver un
billet il fallait s'y prendre avant sans
garantie pour les français on avait déjà
acheté et ticket pour la finale il ya
plus d'un an sur internet
maintenant qu'on a les tickets mais tant
pis on va voir au portugal grèce
ça se vend très cher ils demandent des
prix
nous on a du mal à gagner ils m'ont
vraiment des prix
fraîcheur au coeur de lisbonne les
supporters y ont installé leur camp de
base au fil des minutes
de plus en plus de portugais les
rejoignent toujours avec la sérénité qui
a marqué 7 euros jusqu'à présent
l'angoissent et peut-être dans le bus
des portugais la sélection a quitté sa
résidence d'al kocheh t il ya tout juste
deux heures une haie d'honneur de
milliers de portugais doit la porter
vers une nuit historique à paris
maintenant ce sont les deux communautés
grecques et portugaises qui se prépare
en cours angers à distance leur champion
comme le montre ce reportage de julia
delage et grégory vasseur une star est
née
elle s'appelle luis figo en france toute
la communauté portugaise est derrière
son équipe nationale
ça fait presque 800 mille supporters ce
matin à l'église
même le curé a souhaité bonne chance de
footballeur et on s'arrachait les
maillots des futurs héros on va gagner 3
à 20
j'espère pour touver banier qui
kidnappent de la force à concourir à au
ballon j'ai un gagnant belge a même
grimpé de monde
et puis on va faire la fête à changer
les à conviction il gagne rien de sûr
alors ce midi dans ce restaurant
portugais
l'espoir est en rouge et vert à gagner
face aux nouveaux organes mais je peux
faire sa seule porte
mais voilà il ya les autres les grecs
mauvais souvenir lors du premier match
ils ont battu les portugais depuis le
début de la compétition les dieux du
foot sont avec les grecs
ce soir c'est le peuple qui portera lic
au mondial et le hamas car on a préparé
5 juillet à cet accessoire 5000 acier la
musique arts fous et on va casser
ce soir la guerre de troie n'aura pas
lieu mais tous les coups sont permis en
guise de belle hélène un ballon rond bon
mauvais augure les grecs eux ont déjà
leur porte bonheur et nous vous
retrouvons florent gautreau en direct du
stade de la luz à lisbonne
fatma un peu partagé de cette fièvre qui
monte à une bonne demi heure du coup
d'envoi n'y avait pas triste les
portugais espère que le stade de la luz
c'est à dire le stade de la lumière va
éclairer d'un jour nouveau le palmarès
pourtant vierge pour l'instant vierge de
la sélection portugaise l'ambiance sera
forcément belle dans ce stade de 65
mille places puisqu'il ya cinquante
mille portugais mais aussi treize mille
grecs qui font beaucoup de bruit et qui
sont arrivés il ya déjà bien longtemps
dans le stade de la luz ici alors il ya
le match lui-même une opposition de
style entre les grecs qui ont une
défense de fer et des portugais qui ont
une très bonne défense aussi mais aussi
des joueurs offensifs de talent c'est
une finale inédite je pense qu'on va se
régaler malgré ce qu'on a pu dire ces
derniers et ces derniers jours c'est une
belle finale qui nous attend et puis il
ya cette promesse la promesse du gardien
de but portugais ricardo qui a dit que
en cas de victoire du portugal
il ferait le pèlerinage de fatima
c'est-à-dire 130 km à pied
c'est vous dire si les portugais ont la
foi et nous on va se régaler ce soir sur
france 2 en effet rendez vous dans ce
site après ce journal merci florent
gautreau hamoud de football encore après
la défaite des bleus le capitaine de
l'équipe de france marcel desailly a
décidé de mettre un terme à sa carrière
internationale
âgé de 35 ans marcel dessailly avoue
être moins performant le festival
d'avignon prend sa revanche se prend un
nouveau départ après le séisme de l'an
dernier et avec une nouvelle équipe à sa
tête avignon était à un tournant
un festival qui commence plus tôt et
dans la rue au delà des remparts se fit
jouve jean moulin
avis lui on n'avait jamais de simples de
drôles de machines
les airs de techno parade et des façades
tapissé d'image vidéo qui met en vedette
les habitants de la ville et de sa
banlieue après le traumatisme de l'année
l'action de l'an dernier la nouvelle
équipe du festival a concocté cette
potion magique pour motiver la ville
j'habite près de la cité louise roux
donc je suis parti là bas est une énigme
on a l'impression de se trouver dans une
phase de processions dans laquelle c'est
toute la ville qui se retrouvent ya tous
les âges dégât social il ya vraiment
quelque chose de très sympathique ancrer
le festival dans la vie locale en
offrant une tribune un consens chaque
spectateur peut devenir acteur en
racontant sur les murs de la ville sa
relation avec le théâtre protestent en
acteur il va avoir une attitude qu'on
aurait aimé avoir et plus con de sport
parce qu'on est dans le cadre de la
société si les images qui nous reste
c'est tous les jours seulement je vois
des images c'est du matin au soir et
sans matin au milieu de la foule le
ministre de la culture a joué lui aussi
la partition de la réconciliation
promesse d'un nouveau système
d'assurance chômage pour les
intermittents et voeux de réussite au
premier festival de france
tout simplement parce que les uns et les
autres on doit être réunie par la
volonté de faire que les artistes et les
techniciens de notre pays puissent faire
rayonner leur talent voilà suivre
évidemment il faudra attendre
l'ouverture officielle jeudi prochain
pour savoir si avignon a retrouvé sa
place dans le coeur des festivaliers
s'ils se termine cette édition
programmée pour vous laisser voir
maintenant la finale de l'euro 2000 car
son direct sur france 2 portugal grèce
et la cérémonie clôture de l'euro 2004
excellente fin de soirée sans notre
chaîne